it's great to uh welcome back today
peter joseph who's the founder of the
zeitgeist movement
and director and writer of the film
inter-reflections uh of course based on
his book
uh peter it's so great to have you back
on thank you david i appreciate you
having me hope you're doing well
so i i'm curious um
so much has happened over the last four
years and in particular over the last
couple of weeks really since the the
november election with
um you know literally dozens and dozens
of events that previously
we would imagine to be extraordinarily
unlikely in the united states i'm
curious on a few different levels
number one based on your the analysis
and the perspective that you've talked
about on our program before
that you have about the way the united
states is organized
are the events of the last few weeks
that that unlikely or is it exactly the
type of thing that your perspective
would would suggest is inevitable in
some sense
well the specifics are hard to pinpoint
but this kind of
um right-wing insurrection coming from
what i feel is many many generations of
lower-class oppression
isn't necessarily unpredictable you know
the the
there's this kind of a short-term
picture and a long-term picture as with
anything when it comes to
to uh the human condition in terms of
causality and human behavior
so on one side if you look at the events
of
january 6th you have this rather sparse
insurrection so to speak kind of a
satire of a coup
if you will if you really kind of look
at it when they storm the capital
and then you relate that clearly to a
figurehead that has deep cult of
personality and has been propo
promoting things in his self-interest
with no responsibility
and people have flocked to him and they
believed him and this is where we end up
so that's one perspective i don't think
you can just blame for example donald
trump explicitly donald trump came from
somewhere he's a manifestation of
something
i mean if look at his character in and
of himself he represents
really a kind of kind of extreme
caricature of what capitalist society is
right
it's really about people i mean he's
literally groomed into this since his
father's time
and he knows how to angle he's
professional angler and there's a
there's a line there with morality where
someone goes from being a
good businessman to being effectively a
criminal and i think there's debate as
to how gray that area is when you're
dealing
with exploitation and gaming because
that's what our society is we're gaming
that's what people do
that's the only theory that really
supports the kind of behavior that our
economy does is game
theory as people have modeled in the
past in terms of who will be successful
and who will not
so there's that so you have that kind of
character that comes from society
and then on the other side you have
people and again i it's it's sad because
people become so upset
when they look at these images and they
see the they see it effectively a kind
of domestic
terrorist heir to this right-wing
insurgency and
obsessed with conspiracies they don't
believe anything it's easy to be upset
with those people but they have they
came from somewhere there's
a reason why they have evolved to where
they've become it's not just donald
trump as i said before
i think this society in america due to
socioeconomic inequality something that
we spoke about years ago in my book
the new human rights movement it's the
core focus of that book
socioeconomic inequality is one of the
largest drivers of destabilization
than anything it is uh it is the
ultimate uh precondition so to speak
sociologically
that forces people into a kind of
antagonism even in a wealthy society
such as the united states
the haves and the have-nots have become
so severe throughout the years and if
people don't understand why they
understand the mechanics they understand
the history
they start to feel they start to feel
like they're left behind
so as bizarre as it is that you have a
white culture
in america that now feels they're
oppressed you know given the true
history
of america where obviously the white man
particularly is far from the most
depressed
but this is manifest from this what i
believe class inequality
and i think there's a great deal of
sociological research epidemiological
study that supports that
so for me the solution to all of this is
create more economic equality
ultimately that's really the most
critical thing society can do at this
point
to help it stop the instability that i
think is only going to keep growing in
many different levels
from the standpoint of um we'll let
i'll frame this up in a slightly
different way and get get your thoughts
on it
um whenever we we've seen over the last
four years
the next high bar of crazy reached
sometimes there will be this feeling of
okay this is now
over the line and nobody is going to be
okay with this
and then we hear oh actually it
there's people who are okay with it and
then you see the social media posts and
then you see
the short memory uh that that many have
for for these sorts of things
and you see the way that the the media
apparatus
sort of creates an environment where no
matter
what takes place someone is there yet
that you can point to that will actually
say this is actually okay or defended in
some way
and we could if we say what was the
origin of this
we could come up with a lot of different
starting points
but in terms of the political media
landscape
i often think back to the reagan welfare
queen
meme of this imaginary woman who's
having all these kids and getting rich
off of it
and has a cadillac and like once you
believe that then you go into
immigrants are dangerous and then you go
into trickle-down economics or whatever
right like fill in the blanks
and then you get to hugo chavez and
dominion
and whatever stole the election like the
ultimate caricature that we heard over
the last couple of months
is that a fair way to talk about the
history and
that that makes it about a 35-year
history or would you
kind of frame it up in a different way
well i think that you're you're touching
upon how
two things how belief systems come to be
and belief systems share
shared uh excuse me a common
architecture
so going back to reagan thatcher and the
rise of neoliberalism
where thatcher i believe her quote was
there is no society
she's all about the individual and this
sort of
narcissistic um righteous
self-individualism
came forward that clearly has been
deeply
caustic and if you believe things like
well you get what you work for
or you just have to pull yourself up by
your bootstraps if you believe that
people have complete free will and it's
all up to them which is that general
gesture of all of this
then you're going to not care very much
about people that are actually suffering
legitimately because of the very
structure of the system did not have the
same advantages that other people do
because of the longer long generation of
inequality in many facets of that but
yeah i agree with you absolutely
it's uh it's in the book i remember
writing a whole section on
how the kind of right-wing mindset can
be created
and how particularly from that
standpoint
how this if you like for example if you
believe
that you get what you work for then you
probably also believe that
people that commit crime have absolutely
total responsibility
right forget their they're in poverty
forget what their life condition was
so you end up you know with that that
kind of distorted value system based on
narrow individualism and i think that
also is very much part of the society
because of the economic system once
again so my causality as you know david
it's really all about what our economy
has done to us sociologically
and obviously psychologically and if you
have people that are
stuck in a system regardless of the
reality of our condition regardless of
our potentials for say post scarcity um
and they're fighting with each other
because of the structure not because we
have to
but because of the structure you're
going to have antagonism you're going to
have racism
you're going to have all this group
versus group stuff you see it in
microcosms you see it macrocosms
i was on another podcast the other day
and i was reminded that
in west virginia uh i'm from the south
and i had friends a friend of a friend
from west virginia and they were
describing to me
something surreal and how in west
virginia before nafta
the south and the north actually were at
odds because
of economic strife if you can believe
that just like you saw
you see in italy in the north and south
historically as well which
also generated mob stuff but it wasn't
until nafta came along and jobs were
taken
by people in the global south that
people started to hate people from the
global stuff they started to hate
mexicans so you see that antagonism as
well so that's a good coral area
so one of the calls related to this that
i get
frequently recently when i when i hear
from my audience is
how do we fix this and one of the
reactions i've had is if we grant that
it's taken
34 to pick the reagan thatcher example
35 40 years to get into this
it would be unreasonable to expect that
in a two four
or six year period of time we would get
out of it and some of the things that
have to be changed are
on the one hand as you're talking about
the sort of structure of the financial
system
and inequality on the other hand i
when people ask me how can i convince my
aunt
that she's wrong i think that that's a
that's what we might call a retail
strategy
and we could have that conversation but
it's less relevant to the fact that you
probably need a decade or longer
of cultural and economic uh and
educational change to really start
changing these things
it would other than by dictatorship i
don't know how you achieve
the type of change that has taken place
over 40 years in a short period of time
i i certainly uh can sympathize with
that sentiment
i would say on a certain level the
cultural shifts required particularly
when it comes to something like racism
which i do believe could subside greatly
in this country and beyond
it would take more than that because
racism has a snowball effect
racism started as a
as a legal construct where in pre-excuse
me in slavery period in
early america and many people don't
realize this the
indentured servants that were imprisoned
in in europe they were
taken over here they were used for about
seven years then they could be free
that was not the best business
investment from the standpoint of the
plantation owners and they started to
learn
about the african transatlantic slave
trade
where the kings in africa were
kidnapping their own people and
literally selling them to the dutch and
other
other slave ships and they were brought
over to america as a new investment but
the fact that these people had black
skin had no relevance it wasn't until
later in fact they even intermarried
with
indentured servants and had kids this is
it wasn't this
taboo it wasn't until the illegal
construct of race was created to fortify
racism in and of itself
and create an excuse for it ultimately
and then after the civil war
excuse me after after the um after the
after these civil wars but before that
the legal construct was firm a lot
formalized even more so
so the poor black people could be
subservient to the poor white people to
avoid any kind of upheaval dr martin
luther king wrote about this
uh eloquently how the birth of racism
came to be and it's not what people
think it is so now you have families
that are
racist they've been racist for
generations they teach racist values to
their kids how do you stop that
obviously that take generations but the
economic
foundation is still there and i strongly
believe the stress
of this strife and groupism this group
antagonism of our society is to blame
and if you can get rid of that
to whatever degree it's going to have an
equivalent positive effect on people's
bigotry
so to answer your question i would say
to people obviously you need policy
shifts to create more equality i am
again i'm for
demarcatization i have gone through the
gamut in my mind and analysis i'm not a
marxist and i don't
subscribe to anything socialist in any
kind of traditional sense i look at it
from a systems
science perspective and what we know uh
in sociology and of course efficiency
when it comes to systems
we could go on the tangent of why the
system is unsustainable ecologically and
so on
uh that's a big part of it as well but
in terms of this sociology
excuse me you have to start giving
people what they need directly
so you should be in favor of something
like ubi as a stepping stone people
should
should literally want there to be
ultimately free food and free
transportation
and a free foundation there should be
that we have the resources to do that
so first like people need to understand
that and they don't understand that if
we have
our needs supplied and i'm not talking
about luxuries and excess we could still
have that as a top-tier market reality
right
but you give people what they need so no
one's in poverty anymore
then you're going to see these shifts
happen and people need to understand
that that is not some kind of inhibition
of people's freedom and the propaganda
that we have or people just can't even
handle that concept we can't even talk
about universal health care in america
because some will inevitably attribute
it to socialism and then think we're
going to be in some gulag eventually
because we have universal health care
right so you see the point but i i can't
answer that question in any kind of
explicit way
um i have plenty of proposals that i've
talked about it's obviously education
but you need to have policy shifts and i
will say this eventually
through a femoralization which is this
more with less phenomenon it is to me
the the only real economic
wealth that we have and it's not wealth
in the sense of a physical good it's
wealth in the sense of an extremely
efficient process
jeremy rifkin refers it to it as zero
marginal cost
in reference to um to the current
society where we become so efficient in
a given area
where we've created technology that can
can perform actions at such great
efficiency they become cheaper and
cheaper and cheaper and smaller and
smaller and smaller
you know the big computer you know 50
years ago weighed many tons
took enormous amount of energy cost
millions of dollars now your cell phone
ship is more powerful
that applied to just about everything in
society economically
is where i think localization and a
return to a kind of community-driven
high-tech reality where people get off
the grid
of normal state control i don't mean
state in a derogatory way but
there's the limitations of using a
telecom company the limitations of
having to
buy your food from a major corporation i
believe that people act
accordingly and this is the kind of
stuff i get into at the end of my my
film into reflections
which begins what will be the second
film and i've commented on this
in my book i don't want to go into too
much detail but it's about getting off
the grid
of the market system as fast as we can
through localization
and i'm working on a big lecture in
march describing a platform
where people can come in and start
engaging and feel what it's like
to have to have the community resilience
and to engage in networks
that don't use money let me talk a
little bit so the
this concept of um of zero marginal cost
is interesting
many people are familiar with the
economic concept of diminishing marginal
cost so if you imagine building a
factory to make one pair of shoes
that's a huge fixed cost investment and
of course as you scale up and you can
make more and more shoes more quickly
the additional cost per pair of shoes
goes down but it's still
positive it's still something it's just
not as much as previously
right talk a little bit about how zero
marginal cost is possible and in what
areas it would be possible i think
you know we see it already when it comes
to digital transfer
i mean music while it costs money to
create even though substantially less
than it did before
uh can be transferred across the
internet at zero cost you have
the comment excuse me of the cost of
electricity that's it
films obviously anything in the digital
realm is the easiest example you know it
used to be
you'd have a big film projector then we
had a dvd now you can have free
distribution ultimately
so that's the easiest example but zero
marginal cost could apply to say
transportation systems if they were
efficiently created so you have
automated car systems you have
even the early subway systems that we
have if
if done correctly it's still gonna cost
something which means ultimately there's
going to be some kind of labor
some some kind of resource investment
but if it's done with the proper
efficiency there's no reason for the
public to have to submit to pay for it
and that can be applied to food systems
look at the efficiency of vertical farm
systems as
as has been researched and as i've also
talked about the past the amount of
resources is substantially less the
amount of water is substantially less
and you could easily have vertical farm
systems localized where it's so
efficient people don't need to pay for
it
it doesn't mean that there isn't labor
so there's always going to be some kind
of labor but think about it i use this
example what if instead of working 40
hours a week someone
only had to work five right would they
do that if they could get what they
needed without pay
i think they would i think most people
if they were presented with that
they very much would um i so
with many of these systems it also
sounds like it's not necessarily
about nominal zero marginal costs but
eliminating waste
makes it a net zero like for the food
system is a great example where when you
look at
how much is left in the fields because
by the time it gets to the grocery store
it would be bruised
and then how much is thrown out by the
grocery store because by the next
morning it would be
like but the waste elimination could
make it a net zero
yeah absolutely i mean it's all kind of
subjective it depends on how you think
about labor and energy that goes into
something so
obviously everything has a quote cost if
you put it in the framework of labor and
energy but yeah absolutely i completely
agree
uh the the inefficiencies of our current
system are so
so extreme because of what we've done
the average american food plate
moves about 2 000 miles before it makes
it to your plate
which is obviously that's not the way an
economy would function
especially since there's plenty of
resources and land to localize food
production
and when you do that the efficiency
increases the ultimate element of
efficiency has to do with networking
just like on your cell phone you have
all of these things that used to require
tons and tons of apps there's a guy
named peter diamandis and he
did a calculation that the app potential
on your phone was worth millions of
dollars
say number of decades ago because you
don't need a separate audio player or a
separate film player
so the networking of things making
things as unified as possible is the
ultimate post scarcity
efficiency mechanism and that's what we
don't do in our society we have
corporations that are all divided
everyone's competing with each other you
have cell phone companies that are not
sharing an open source they're
constantly making new little
improvements they don't know what
they're going to do
the amount of waste created is is
staggering because there's no
collaborative environment
it's a post-facto collaboration
ultimately um which doesn't help
anything
so there's a lot to be said on that i my
ultimately my
focus these days economically is on post
scarcity and
if we can achieve i'll just comment on
this by the way i did see another
interview that you did a while back on
post scarcity
and it was it was a good interview but i
i noticed that there's a
when people speak about this they tend
to obsess about you know things like
automation
and the the potentials but really post
scarcity is
is a economic world view in our current
society
to have deficiency means to be able to
make money
for people to be insecure means they're
more likely to go out and buy something
efficiency sustainability and
conservation are the enemies of this
kind of system because the more problems
there are
the more money can be made we have a in
china one of the richest men in the
world
makes all of his money multi-billionaire
off of water bottling
so it's not good to have clean water if
if you know you want to make a bunch of
money
right so you have to shift away from
that kind of what effectively is
artificial scarcity creation that the
market system
just does naturally it's this is what
its natural incentive is
and if people's mindset gets shifted by
that and suddenly people are restricting
things they don't even know it you have
value system disorders that are created
so and that's really where i think the
root of the ecological crisis is and
i'll add one more thing to that on this
small tangent
our entire society is pushed by
consumption so
you know people have to buy things they
have to create demand
that demand inspires jobs people have
the jobs to get money to get purchasing
power and then the whole cycle continues
if you have a reduction of people
needing things for whatever reason such
as durability sustainability
confidence you're going to harm the
economy as we know it
and that's a very that's a very caustic
place to be as a civilization
yeah i mean i think in our next
conversation we should just focus on
environment and
and ecological issues but what you're
saying reminds me of uh within the food
system of something michael pollan
describes really well which is that
just our basic ingredients are very hard
to make very profitable
because they're just ingredients you
can't do much to them and that's where
this idea of well
let's take the corn and we'll make it
inedible in its in its
ingredient form but we can grow a ton of
it in an acre
and then we can extract it and break it
down to its component parts and create
food products which most people don't
even really know they want but will
create marketing in order to tell people
instead of just buying corn on the cob
here's something made with a corn
extract
and that's what you should go and and i
mean that's that's essentially what
you're describing across
multiple industries yeah ultimately
ultimately
and then you have just the psychological
disorder simultaneously when people's
values
are pushed into a social circumstance
excuse me people's values are
being acclimated into a social
environment where people get more and
more
and they want to keep up with the
joneses i mean i i was on the last
person to get a cell phone i
really didn't have the motivation to do
so but over time
everyone had one everyone's like oh why
can't i call you why can't i text you
and suddenly social inclusion kicks in
right and that is kind of a virus in our
society
so to speak where this need for social
inclusion that's what advertising does
it manipulates
our sense of sociality making us feel
like we
are missing out on something and that of
course is another conversation in and of
itself
yeah and then when you get this stuff
thanks to hedonic adaptation you don't
really feel any better about now having
had it because
you're moving to the next thing uh peter
joseph founder
and z of the zeitgeist movement director
and writer of the film
inter-reflections it's always great to
talk to you and let's let's do it again
let's do it thank you david